yeah what
um what are you listening to these days
we need a butcher love you some Betty
have you actually I know all this [ __ ]
let me shout out shout out to the
Griselda boys man Conway Benny locks of
course Jay Knox
King's disease three fire
super fire yeah
it's amazing it's actually probably the
best Nas album since
I don't know dude
it's a it's the best King's disease
I mean if him and hitboy put four albums
on two years it's the best moment what
was your ill now from Queens well I know
you're from Queens you're from Jamaica
right you know South America so
I'm gonna lose that
I was out with
um
Taraji P Henson one night
we go to some little spot a date
yeah yeah nice boom
what do you think I don't know
nice
um
I see nice there
I had to pull up I had to get a bottle
of champagne I got the opportunity to
chop it up when I see a drone
man to man one-on-one that's amazing
end at night
we was having dinner with
Brad Pitt
Forest Whitaker who I really like my
dude
I got to see Prince played his crib
what the [ __ ] so in the same night
you're with Taraji P Henson on a date
you go to dinner with Angelina Jolie and
Brad Pitt
and you see right here and I'll see you
now shout out to go hey did you watch
ghost dog back in the day the force
Whittaker movie where he was the samurai
the Riza did the soundtrack it was
amazing shout out to him uh hello he was
a what he was a samurai in in in in New
York and he was flying pigeons and Wu
Tang did the soundtrack it was called
Ghost Dog fire uh Samurai yeah Forest
Whitaker he's like a black samurai he
like lives by the samurai code
super Fire movie with that being said
you saw Prince perform the same night in
his crib at his house
was Nas at his house no no I was at this
little Club